JUDGE, BACK TO YOU.
>> THE VIOLENT CRIME THIS
HOLIDAY WEEKEND EXTENDED FAR
BEYOND HIGHLAND PARK.
NEARBY IN THE CITY OF CHICAGO,
OVER 70 WORKSHOPS, AND EIGHT
KILLED THIS WEEKEND ALONE.
HERE IN NEW YORK, AND AID TO
MAYOR ADAMS WAS WHILE SCOUTING
THE LOCATION FOR AN UPCOMING
EVENT.
ACCORDING TO THE NYPD, SHOOTING
SORT OVER THE 2022 JULY 4 WE CA
COMPARED TO 2021.
AND OVER AT PHILADELPHIA, TWO
OFFICERS WERE SHOT MONDAY NIGHT
DURING A SHOOTING AT A FOURTH O
JULY FESTIVAL.
THANKFULLY, BOTH HAVE BEEN
RELEASED FROM THE HOSPITAL.
SADLY THE VIOLENCE PLEADING
PLAGUE AND MAKE MAJOR CITY HAS
BECOME TOO COMMON AS FAR LEFT
LEADERS REFUSED TO TAKE THE
ISSUE OF VIOLENT CRIME SERIOUSL
AND INSTEAD CONTINUE TO CODDLE
VIOLENT OFFENDERS AS CDS DEFEND
INTO LAWLESSNESS.
GENTLEMEN, GOOD EVENING.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING OUT AND ABOUT
.
I WILL START WITH YOU, LEO.
OUT AND ABOUT, THE FOURTH OF
JULY HOLIDAY, GOING TO BARBECUES
, IT ALMOST MAKES YOU
SHOCKED WHETHER OR NOT YOU WANT
TO GO OUTSIDE.
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
LET'S BE HONEST.
CRIME AND MURDER ARE ACCEPTED I
DEMOCRATIC CITIES.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE I BEEN ON
THE SHOW WITH YOU ON HANNITY
WHERE EVERY WEEK IN CHICAGO, LO
ANGELES, NEW YORK, PHILADELPHIA
PEOPLE ARE BEING MURDERED,
PEOPLE ARE BEING VICTIMS OF
CRIME.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THESE ARE CITIES RUN BY PEOPLE
OF COLORS.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY LOOKS THE
OTHER WAY.
THEY DON'T COVER THIS.
WE COVER COVERAGE ON THIS
NETWORK, BUT IT HAPPENS.
THEY ACCEPT CRIME AND THEY
ACCEPT MURDER.
I AM SETTING HERE RIGHT NOW ON
TUESDAY YOU AND I KNOW THERE'S
GOING TO BE MORE MURDERS IN NEW
YORK THIS WEEKEND IN CHICAGO, I
PHILADELPHIA.
ONE LAST POINT, YOU HAVE A MAYO
IN PHILADELPHIA WHERE OFFICERS
ARE BEING SHOT AT TALKING ABOUT
TAKING AWAY LAW-ABIDING CITIZEN
GUNS I'VE GOT NEWS FOR YOU,
CRIMINALS WILL NEVER TURN IN
THEIR GUNS.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CHICAGO.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT CHICAGO.
GUNS ARE ILLEGAL IN CHICAGO.
YET, WHAT IS DRIVING ME CRAZY
ABOUT THIS DIRT BAG I DON'T EVE
WANT TO MENTION HIS NAME, THE
KID WITH A GUN, HE WAS HOMICIDAL
, HE WAS SUICIDAL, THEY
HAVE A RED FLAG LAW, THEY TOOK
17 KNIVES OUT OF HIS HOME.
POLICE WERE AT HIS HOUSE ALL TH
TIME ACCORDING TO NEIGHBORS.
HE THREATENED TO KILL MEMBERS O
HIS FAMILY.
MEAN HOW MUCH DO YOU NEED FOR A
RED FLAG LAW.
A FEW MONTHS LATER THE KID GETS
A FIREARM CARD?
I HAVEN'T EVEN STARTED WITH THE
SOCIAL MEDIA.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE SOCIAL MEDIA
THIS KID, IT IS ALL THEY ARE.
AM I WRONG?
>> ABSOLUTELY, JUDGE.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF
THE LIBERAL NETWORKS ARE NOT
REALLY TALKING ABOUT.
THE REALITY IS SOCIAL MEDIA IS
BIG PART OF THIS.
THINK ABOUT IT, THESE COMPANIES
ARE NOT EVEN SHARING INFORMATION
.
WE KNOW THESE INDICATORS ARE OU
HERE PARADIGM TALK SICK OF
TALKING ABOUT THESE MASS
SHOOTINGS HAPPENING AND THE
UNITED STATES WHERE THE SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES THEY SEE THE
CONTENT ON THE PLATFORM AND
AREN'T SHOWING IT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT A BE
REACTIONARY AND BEING MISSED AN
COME UP AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS I
WE DON'T GET THE INFORMATION,
THERE IS NO WAY TO INTERVENE TO
STOP THE ATTACK FROM HAPPENING
VERY I TO WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE.
WE ARE COMING UP ON THE SIX
UNIVERSE RATE OF THE MASS
SHOOTING ATTACK IN DALLAS, TEXA
THAT CLAIMED THE LIVES OF FIVE
POLICE OFFICERS.
TICKET NOT ONLY REMINDING PEOPL
OF THAT, BUT IN THIS CRAZY WORLD
, LEO, YOU'VE GOT POLICE
OFFICERS AND IF THEY DIDN'T SEE
WHAT WAS HAPPENING AT THAT
FOURTH OF JULY PARADE YOU HAVE
THE COPS RUNNING IN THERE, YOU
SEE THE SWAT TEAM YOU SEE THEM
ON THEIR TRUCKS, YOU SEE THEM
ALL SUITED UP AND YOU THINK
THANK GOD IT'S AMERICA AND THE
CALVARY IS COMING.
THE PEOPLE ON THE LEFT THEY WAN
TO DAM THE COPS, THEY WANTED TH
POLICE AND TAKE AWAY THEIR
ABILITY TO FIGHT CRIMINALS.
WHAT IS GOING ON, LEO?
>> DEMOCRATS CONTROL OF THE
WHITE HOUSE, DEMOCRATIC CONTROL
OF CONGRESS FOR THREE YEARS AGO
DEFUND THE POLICE IS STILL ALIV
AND WELL IN THE SAME DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS, THEY ARE SWAMPED WITH
PRIVATE SECURITY, BUT THEY DON'
WANT TO PROTECT LAW ENFORCEMENT
NEVER IN MY LIFETIME HAVE
OFFICERS BEEN UNDER ATTACK AND
LESS SUPPORTED IN THE CITIES.
THE PROSECUTORS, DEMOCRATIC
PROSECUTORS IN THESE CITIES,
THEY ARE SOFT ON CRIME.
CRIMINALS ARE HAPPY TO LIVE IN
DEMOCRATIC CITIES.
>> THEY'RE NOT SOFT ON CRIME,
THE TRUTH IS THEY WANT THE
CRIMINALS OUT AND ABOUT.
THEY WANT TO LET THEM OUT OF
PRISON.
I LOVE YOU, LEO, AND I MEAN THA
I AM AGREEING WITH YOU, THE
TRUTH IS THEY WANT TO LET THEM
OUT.
GOD BLESS THAT CRIMINALS, GIVE
THEM A BREAK.
>> AND 83 PERCENT INCREASE OF
THE MONK SLIPPED VIOLENT
OFFENDERS, WE HAVE TO DO MORE T
BLOCK THESE PEOPLE UPGRADE IF
YOU LOOK AT 2012, OBAMA SHUT
DOWN ALL THE PRIVATE PRISONS
THAT WE HAVE THE USE THE
ARGUMENTS OF OUR PRISONS ARE
CROWDED.
THE BOTTOM LINE WHEN WE NEED TO
START REOPENING OUR PRESENCE,
GET THE VIOLENT OFFENDERS OFF
THE STREET AND LOCK THESE PEOPL
UP SO WE CAN KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFE